hi I'm Erik Bosse and HBO's Westworld
season 2 has ended leaving those of us
who obsessively watch the show slightly
less confused than usual which is a big
win as far as I'm concerned there are
just enough where deals and clues to
piece together what's going on that is
until a post-credits scene what is this
an Avengers movie not enough depth now
that the season is over and we are past
this risk of our theories expiry in a
week later when a new episode blows our
minds in a different way let's look back
at this season as the 10 hour movie it
secretly is and explain its lingering
mysteries and spoiler warning in case
you haven't seen the finale episode ok
first and foremost what the hell was
going on with Bernard this season so in
season 2 Bernards story was split into
two timelines one in the immediate
aftermath of the season 1 massacre and
another 2 weeks later when a more
confused Bernard joins the dello
security team this finale episode tied
the two timelines together now I plan to
make another video that goes into these
timelines in detail but the gist is
timeline a shows Bernard escaping the
massacre with Charlotte Hale teaming up
with LC and learning the parks true
agenda rejoining Dolores and killing her
to stop her from wiping out the data in
the forge then Bernard witnesses
Charlotte murdering LC to cover it all
up so he spends the remaining 12 hours
before the Della's team arrives
constructing a hosts version of
Charlotte and replacing the real
Charlotte with her he gave this
Charlotte Dolores his coat bernard
leaves himself on the beach after
scrambling his memories so that the
delos team that finds him won't be able
to pry those thoughts out of him
he also says goodbye to the vision of
Ford who had been guiding him Bernard
realizes that since he deleted Ford from
his code the voice he had heard was
actually himself
this suggests that Bernard has reached a
true bicameral mind of consciousness
realizing that the second voice in his
head isn't that of a God but his own
that brings us to timeline B Bernards
journey with Carl strand in the dello
steam the Charlotte's that joins them in
this timeline is actually Dolores and
disguised notice how in all of these
scenes she now wears body armor this is
all part of Bernards plan to sneak
Dolores out of the park when Charlotte /
Dolores is scanned at the end of the
episode she's clear meaning Bernard must
have omitted the explosive inside of
every hosts neck we also learned this
episode that Bernard
actually Dolores is creation this is
what we were seeing in this third
bernard timeline the fidelity test
between him and dolores in the past the
original human Arnold created Dolores of
course but over time she recorded his
bio details enough to recreate him as a
host but the true AI host Arnold would
inevitably ended suicide
so Dolores changed him to create the
sweet sweet Bernard that we know the
finale scene cleverly illustrated this
robot creating robot concept by
including MC Escher's hands drawing hand
sketch and that brings us to Dolores
this season and the question what are
the door the forge and the valley beyond
season two showed us an awakened Dolores
following the blood thirsty Wyatt
narrative seeking something called the
valley beyond the finale shows Bernard
and Dolores reaching the forge which is
a massive underground database storing
all of the backup drives of the park
this Forge is the golden egg everyone is
after it contains the bio data secretly
recorded from the human guests we
learned this season at West world's
secret agenda was to collect data on the
humans through recordings from the hosts
in the guests hats fellows could do all
kinds of evil stuff with this data but
the implication is that they plan to use
it to build AI clone versions of real
people basically to offer immortality to
the elite of society
we saw them conducts these fidelity
experiments with AI clones of James
dillos Charlotte could use this human
data to create host versions of all the
humans who were killed in the massacre
basically covering that scandal up when
Dolores and Bernard tore through the
forge its inner computer manifests in
the form of Logan he tells in that
humanity isn't all that different from
robot algorithms that all humans also
mindlessly go through the motions
according to their inner programming
incapable of change
they are just passengers thus this
episode's title during this tour we can
see in a background various scenes from
season 1 suggesting that all these
interactions were being used to
structure a paradise the digital Eden
that the host a eyes could escape into
this is what the valley beyond is the
forge creates a door it's a rift in
reality that only the host can see the
hosts run through this door and
transport their minds into this digital
Eden while their Empty host bodies
tumble down into the ravine
in the real world which of course gets
flooded resulting in the lake of host
bodies that Barnard finds leader but
rather than letting these host minds
live in peace Dolores has different
plans in the forge library she reads
books on specific humans this includes a
book on Charlotte Hale also a book on
Carl strand the pages of these books are
written in sheet music for a player
piano which echoes ford's final speech
votes on Beethoven and Chopin never died
they simply became music now Dolores
initially plans to erase all the host
data but after Bernard kills her she
instead uses the dello satellites to
send them somewhere else and this change
in behavior suggests a higher level of
consciousness and Dolores as well so
what's next for Dolores and Bernard well
the final scene showed Bernard Dolores
and Charlotte outside Westworld in the
human world now we had just seen
Charlotte slash Dolores escape with five
host brain pearls in her purse those
could be once for Charlotte Bernard
maybe also Teddy made Abernathy or
others the final chat between Dolores
and Bernard hints at a coming war
against the human race Dolores is
militant while Bernard sees goodness in
humanity there actually appear to be
some parallels with the civil rights
movement with one revolutionary seeking
change through compassion and the other
seeking change through violent upheaval
so I think next season we can expect
Dolores and Bernard to continue this
ethical debate as Dolores wages of war
on mankind meanwhile remember we still
have three sections of the West world
Park yet to be revealed so I assume
we'll get to those as well there's also
more Williams story left to tell so what
happened in the post-credits scene with
William and his daughter well if you man
should stick around through the credits
and not stare at your reflection in the
mirror for hours like I normally do it
the west-world
he's some of this scene with William
descending into the forge to find his
daughter Emily revealing to him that
he's inside his own fidelity test so
what does this mean for William this
season is he a host how is Emily still
alive I'll be at the mirror coach
showrunner Lisa joy actually confirmed
that this post-credits scene takes place
in the distant future that's why the
forge is this dusty ruin now William
actually did kill his daughter Emily in
the previous episode this now is a host
version of her and this William is also
a host reliving his final visit to West
world over and over as these future
hosts try to perfect this AI clones
coding to try to match the real thing
future William will go through the same
endless that
test that he put James dello through
meanwhile back in the present timeline
Williams survived he was found by Stubbs
in the recovery team he'll probably live
on to fight another day to me Williams
role in season 2 was to represent true
human nature he's cruel clever and
cursed and we learned that his main goal
is to conquer death in season one he one
of the stakes to be real for death and
Westworld to be a true option in season
two he gets his wish he entered into a
game with four that led him to suffer
for real and this post-credits scene
teases that william truly will achieve
the immortality he seeks just as a host
trapped in a gilded cage forever and
ever never dark so that covers Dolores
Barnard William and Charlotte but what
about the fate of the other characters
in this finale episode we saw a few
characters make it to the valley beyond
digital Eden Teddy Maeve's daughter
the ghost nation warrior a cachi and his
wife most of the other characters don't
make it made Clementine Hector and
Armistice and the Geisha honey they all
died in the hosts melee at the end of
the finale Felix and Sylvester were
tasked with determining which hosts to
bring back suggesting that Maeve and her
cohorts will probably return meanwhile
human characters like Lea and Elsie both
got shot and died in the finale and one
last big reveal was that Stubbs has also
been a host all this time apparently he
revealed to Charlotte slash Dolores that
Ford also programmed him with a roll and
that's why he allows her to escape know
there are probably a lot more questions
to ask about this season of Westworld
but one question I have for you do you
want Dolores to succeed comment down
below or tweet me directly at EA of us
and keep an eye out for the other
Westworld season 2 timeline breakdown we
got in the works like this video shared
around and subscribe to new rock stars
for deep dives in a west world but also
Game of Thrones another Nolan family
related works thanks for watching freeze
all motor functions that just kidding I
know robots or real wit oh my god
everyone in the office froze No
[Music]